ايلون ماسك مستمر باثاره الجدل في تويتر
من لحظه اعلان نيه شراء الموقع الى
الاستحواذ وحتى الان جديد الى الماس هذه
المره هو طرد موظف بتغريده على موقعه
تويتر لمهندس ناقشه بامور تقنيه نعود
لبدايه القصه الى ماسك قدم اعتذارا عن بطء
تطبيق تويتر في العديد من البلدان خاصه
على الهواتف العامله بنظام التشغيل
اندرويد
تقدم للرد على تغريده ماسك وقال انه عمل
للست سنوات على تويتر لاندرويد واكد ان
حديث ماسك ادعاء خاطئ وفي غير محله
التغريدات والمتبادله بين هوفر ومسك
تواصلت الاخير عاد ليسائل عن ما قام به
المطورون لاصلاح هذا الخلل او البطء بعد
هذا المهندس بسلسله التغريدات تشرح ما قام
به فريقه لتطوير تطبيق تويتر على اندرويد
ثم اغرد
ما الذي يمنع المدير المناقشه تلك المسائل
عبر اجتماع مع الموظفين او برساله عبر
البريد الالكتروني الى ماسك حسم الامر من
خلال رده على تساؤل مغرد اخر سال ماسك عن
سبب قبوله بتصرف كهذا ضمن فريقه ايلون
ماسك غرد بكلمتين فقط انه مطرود ليتلقى
المهندس فرون هوفر اول حاله طرد داخليه في
تويتر بتغريده واكد المطور قرار الفصل
بنشر صوره لجهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص به والذي
لا يمكننه الدخول اليه يمكنه الدخول اليه
بعد قرار فصلته